through
american cosmic and in general you've
interacted with much of the ufo
community you mentioned
ufologists by the way is it
ufologists or is it ufologists it's
ufologists you follow jesus
yeah so first of all wood is a ufologist
and second of all um what have you
learned about this
community of ufologists or also as you
refer to them as
the invisibles or the members of the
invisible college
or just in general people who study ufos
from the different
all the different kinds of groups that
study ufos sure
generally what i found is that
they are okay so people who are
interested in ufos from like
being a kid you know and seeing some
cool movie like star wars or something
and then they become interested and then
they study it as best they can
ufos or uaps they're generally
an honest group of people who are using
their tools
there are generally two types of them um
there are those who believe in the nuts
and bolts like the physical craft
and they believe in that these are
things from other planets
okay so that's like the e t h hypothesis
uh you know um i'm sorry et
hypothesis eth is what we call it yeah
sorry about that
so this is like there's an actual
spaceship like a phys
like something akin but much more
advanced than the rockets we use now
yeah and uh some kind of
not necessarily biological but something
like biological organisms that travel on
these
spaces so this would be like what to the
stars academy
is trying to decipher like how you know
how do they do it
you know maybe we could use that
technology the propulsion and things
like that they look at the rocket
technology
okay so there are those and then there
are people who believe that it's more
consciousness-based okay so these are
your two types
of um ufologists who are known
and these are people who we know about
then i found that there are people who
are quote unquote i call them the
invisibles because
jacques vale in the in the 70s he and um
i think actually alan hynek his
colleague
quoted this is a francis bacon thing by
the way it goes back to
the early modern time period when
scientists could be killed for basically
trying to go outside what the church or
the
government institution determined was
dogma
and so they had to be really careful so
they caught he called the invisible
college
so heinek took that term and returned
reused it or what do you call it um
repurposed it so that he repurposed it
so
that they were still talking to each
other though so what i found to be the
case was that there was a group of
people who were scientists but were not
on the internet you know people today
and students of mine in particular
and my own kids actually they think that
you only exist
if you're on the internet or something
only exists if it's on the internet
and that's of course untrue and so what
i found was that there are
most people who are the most powerful
people of our society and are doing
things
are not on the internet you're not going
to find any trace of them so
a lot of these people are what i call
invisibles people who are studying
at least their work is invisible you
might find them on the internet but
you're going to find that they're part
of the bowling league or something like
that right you will not find
that they are actually engaged in
research about
this topic okay and so i called them the
invisibles because i was surprised to
find them
and i thought well this is no longer the
invisible college
because these people are not even
talking to each other and that's why i
reference
this movie fight club in it you have
an invisible okay and his name is tyler
durden
and he's incredible he does incredible
things
um he's like a person who should not
exist
right because he does so many things
that are amazing
and so i found a person like that and i
call and he's a real person
he's partially on the internet but
nothing that he does
around that topic of ufos is on the
internet so i decided to call him tyler
d
after tyler durden and so these people i
i've turned the ufo fight club because
they work together but they don't know
in fact his boss doesn't know what he
does
they don't talk to each other because
you know the first rule of fight club
same as the second yeah exactly yeah you
don't talk about it no you don't do it
why do you have a sense that um
there's such a i don't want to say fear
but a principle of staying out of the
limelight
i think there's something real and i
think that the use of it
could be um dangerous for people
oh sorry you mean like something real
like there's actual
technology i don't what's the right
terminology here to use this
alien technology
ideas about technology that are
being explored that are dangerous have
made public
that may be become dangerous so i
wouldn't cut you don't have to call it
alien technology you can call it ideas
about alien technology because
i don't know if it's actual alien
technology or not i honestly don't know
but i do know for a fact because it's a
historical fact
that jack parsons and um constantine
tchaikovsky who's russian believed in
these things and believed that they were
downloading
this information whether or not they
were i don't i mean
they definitely created the rocket
technologies that's true
how they did and whether their process
was exactly what they said it was
i don't know so this is the same thing
today so we've got some powerful
technologies going on here and you know
of course we have a military and we have
a military for a reason
every almost every government who needs
a military has one
um and so they're going to um keep these
the way they should be kept in my
interpretation i mean think about it
everybody accepts the fact that we have
a military almost everybody does
why are they so upset then that the
military keeps secrets
yeah well that's that's the nature of
things that we can get into that whole
thing i i
i tend to i've spoken with the cto
lockheed martin
on this um i
obviously read and think about war a lot
it's such a difficult
question because this space this
particular space of technology
there's a gray area that i think is
evolving over time
i think nuclear weapons change the game
in terms of
what should and shouldn't be secret i
think there's already technology that
will enable us to destroy each other and
so there's some sense in which
some technology should be made public
this is the same discussion of um
you know uh between companies which part
of
your technology should you make public
through like for example academic
publications and all that kind of stuff
like how the google search engine works
page rank algorithm or
how the different deep learning like
there's pretty vibrant
machine learning research communities
within google facebook and so on and
they release a lot of different ideas
it's an interesting question like how
dangerous
is it to release some of the ideas i
think it's a gray area that's constantly
changing i do also think it's super
interesting
i wonder if you could elaborate on a
little bit that there's this
gray area between what's actually
real in terms of alien technology
and the belief of it
when held in the minds of really
brilliant people
that they ultimately may produce the
same kind of result
in terms of being able to create new
technologies that are human usable
like is there um
in your mind they're one in the same
as like believing in alien craft
and uh actually being in possession of
an alien craft
i don't think they're the same no belief
is powerful
okay um in
new age communities you know people
think thoughts are things
okay that's been said you know thoughts
are things you can make them happen kind
of thing believe in them enough
it is true that if i believe i can
run a 540 mile i'll do it
okay and i probably will do it and i've
done it before actually um much younger
but i did it
so but my coach is the one that
instilled that belief in me right
and so but can i run like a one minute
mile
no okay so i guess does that answer your
question like
there's only so far belief goes in
generating
reality well yeah i mean i guess that's
what uh just having listened to
jacques valet it seemed like
reality is not was not as important
for the scientific exploration of the
concept of alien technology
i could be wrong but this is what i
think jacques is getting at there are
other ways to access
places in reality other than what we
consider
to be physical right that's what this
consciousness
okay so in like i said so religious
studies
is among other things it's it's looking
at visionary experiences
all right so people do have visionary
experiences they did without drugs
you know they did with drugs they do
with drugs they do
many have them without drugs today and
oftentimes those visionary experiences
correspond to each other now how do we
how do we
make sense of that so you know do these
places actually
exist in a sense i think they do and so
i think that
you know like let's take that very
famous case of a virgin mary apparition
in fatima
where i think there was like a lot of
people thousands and thousands
if not like i think 50 000 or something
like that a lot of people
uh gathered to see what's now
called um the miracle of fatima which
was the spinning of the sun
well a lot of people saw different
things but they all saw some
kind of thing okay so they all saw
different things but it was
something happened okay so i guess the
question is um what are these
places where we access
non what i'd call like non-physical
realities
okay where we actually do get
information we get like who could say
that jack parsons didn't get information
from doing these rituals and
accessing these we have to say that he
actually did
because we see the results of physical
results the same thing with tyler and
that's why i put tyler
in this camp with this tradition
with jack parsons i say that tyler
is is getting these what he calls
downloads and you can see the results of
them
physically he sells them on the nasdaq
he makes millions of dollars from them
he they help people i've seen people who
they've helped
you